cnn's cue ball of concern brian Stelter
slam donald trump for skipping this
year's correspondent dinner in the past
presidents have always shown up even if
they were angry at the press at any
given time and importantly it's it's
useful for White House aides to smoothes
with reporters it's helpful for us to
get to know our sources there's some
value in these sorts of festive events
look it's yet another example of what
we're seeing this administration's
attack against the media it takes many
forms oh geez so now skipping a dinner
is an attack on the media brides really
taking this attack on the press stick to
crazy heights and no offense but maybe
skipping a meal now and then might not
be a bad thing for some people in the
press I include myself that's why I'm
walking more Jessie okay as for
smoothing being useful no for us this
dinner is just an orgy of
self-congratulation
with sweaty lemmings complimenting their
shared opinions while peering over each
other's shoulders to see what coked-up
third-tier celebrity might stumble into
the stinky overcrowded mess hall trust
me the halitosis is so thick you could
cut it with a cake knife of course some
will say Trump's a coward for avoiding
this clown show but that's not cowardice
it's common sense why go to a place
where the entire theme will be orange
man bad featuring the same ironic
platitudes expressed by the same
lunatics who've never offered a thought
that might offend their own tight circle
here's a thought why not hire a host who
doesn't pair it the predictable jokes
imagine a Jordan Peterson Joe Rogan Dave
Rubin that's the real cowardice being
afraid to challenge the media mob
orthodoxy but Greg it's for charity
true but by skipping the dinner Trump is
stripped away the novelty that turned
the original charity event into a thirst
fest for spotlight chasing lollipops
he made it great again it's now about
journalism no wonder they're miserable
no Dana you know what this this event it
was it's supposed to be our charity and
that's good you know what it became it
became events for people like avenatti
Joe that the flame of the moment that
would show up in being you know people
who would invite avenatti yes
exactly exactly what I'm talking about I
went six years in a row
yes administration I'm not a night owl
no you're not
it was like one of your night peep but I
did like to see the folks I'd like to
see people that was fun it was also
always colder than you thought I was
gonna be so you dress up isn't miserable
here's the thing he's not coming to the
dinner guys just like let it go
yes also they do have a point it's not
like he's just skipping the dinner like
oh I got something he's gonna go to a
rally and he's going to say I came here
instead of being with them and he's
going to attack the media so that's
there it's win-win Jesse they get to
sulk and he gets to go look at those
people sulking it's like they got stood
up for the prom yeah and they ruined the
White House Correspondents Dinner party
and now they're complaining that Trump's
not going
they've been brutal to him and see he
doesn't care anymore and this thing
peaked a long time ago they used to have
better celebrities they used to have
better comedians I went a couple years
ago it probably peaked then you know out
of respect what you shouldn't really be
talking about people's physical
characteristics Greg thank you I'm above
all that I know you Laura would do
anything like that
you know I'd also don't like when grown
men seem so concerned and upset yeah
about things it's it's like you're a
grown man is constantly offended what
grown men do you know that are
constantly offended azar the guy on hey
want the good news about this event is
that that they're having like a
journalistic historian Ron Turner yeah
yeah so it's it's actually going back to
its roots so once again Donald Trump has
improved something there's the hair he's
made he's made the Correspondents Dinner
great again are you going are you going
are you I go usually I don't I haven't
followed I have to check it out I've
been invited to a bunch of parties I
haven't found it's but but my feeling is
that you know I I think I agree with
what Dana's saying I think he uses this
to play to right-wing grievance all the
presence of evil
because he's like the nonsense
regurgitator
he takes what you says and then spits it
out and it means something today well
here's what I heard I heard her say he's
going to go out and hold rallies and
he's going to say the press is terrible
here and I'm here with you I'm here with
you I'm not there with those evil people
in the press but he's the guy who talks
about enemy of the press he's the guy
who says fake news and it turns out Cory
the mullah report he's telling more lies
about the news and the media is telling
yeah I wasn't trying to fire Jim this is
a bad correspond to Center Emily you are
you are new to cut this world which you
if you would you go you would probably
like it definitely I'm not no I'm not
you know what you'll miss getting hit on
by jeffrey toobin
really exciting definitely in your intro
and it's really enjoyable I will say
that I found it interesting that stalter
focused what he focuses on every day in
terms of turn apart which is this
administration then why would he care so
much if they come because he says the
two reasons to come are to celebrate the
First Amendment and to raise money for
the journalism scholarship attending
does not preclude either of those and
last time I checked he says he
celebrates the First Amendment daily
with his reporting he says he wants to
schmooze with White House official and
that the point there are a lot of people
from the administration in the White
House who talk to reporters yeah off the
record always like very enjoyable and we
encourage that including the president
all right that's true